وعلى ذكرى عمليات الاعدام الاخيره في
ايران تعود بالذاكره الى عام
1988 جمهوريه الاعدامات التي كان ابراهيم
رئيسي يشرف عليها انذاكر وهذه الجمهوريه
عادت الان حيث لا يجرا فيها الناس على
الاحتجاج ولا يجرؤ فيها المسؤولون على
الانشقاق تقول مجموعه انترناشونال كرايسز
لرويترز هنا مشهد الاعدامات في ايران وضع
الرئيس الايراني ابراهيم رئيسه بمواجهه
المحليه وعالميه واعاده بالذاكره الى
قرارات رئيسي عندما كان عضوا في لجان
الموت التي اشرفت على اعدام مئات المساجين
السياسيين في العاصمه الايرانيه طهران
وفقه طبعا هنا منظمات حقوقيه للشفاء ايسي
على قمع حاد للاحتجاجات اليوم ويقول عنها
مراقبون انها تسببت بمقتل 500 شخص من
متظاهرين ورجال الامن وهذا يردد صدى الدور
الذي لعبه رئيسي الرئيس الايراني في اباده
السجناء السياسيين في عام
1988 وحينها وبعد اسابيع من الهدنه لايقاف
اطلاق النار في يوليو والتي انهى الثماني
سنوات من حرب مضنيه مع العراق اعدمت
السلطات الايرانيه سرا وبشكل جماعي الاف
السجناء من المعارضين المنددين بالنظام
الايراني وشكل وقتها النظام ما اصبح يعرف
باسم لجان الموت في كافه ارجاء ايران
والتي تكونت مشاهدينا من قضاه دينيين
ومدعين ومسؤولين وخبراء استخبارات لتحديد
مصير الاف المعتقلين في محاكمات تعسفيه
استغرقت دقائق فقط وفقا طبعا لتقرير
نشراته منظمه العفو الدولي واليوم وبعد
حوالي ثلاثه عقود تتخوف ايضا المنظمات
الحقوقيه من ان ينجح النظام الايراني من
السيطره على الاحتجاجات التي ترهب الناس
بالاعدامات سرا وعلانيه
[موسيقى]